[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIHAI IONESCU: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to another session of
Payments on Developers Live.
We were hoping to have a partner
join us today, but
unfortunately, they
couldn't make it.
But they promise they will make
it in a couple of weeks.
PENG YING: They promised.
MIHAI IONESCU: We'll
hold them to that.
But nevertheless we have so
many things to talk about.
You will definitely
be entertained.
We have announcements.
We have lesson demos.
And of course, we'll
take questions.
First, we'd like to make
an introduction.
We have a new colleague.
We were telling you that
we were hiring.
And we're very happy we've
made a great hire.
And on my right side here, there
is Nasir Khan, which is
a new developer advocate.
We're very happy to
have you, Nasir.
Tell us a little bit about
yourself and what you will be
working on.
NASIR KHAN: Thank you for
the introduction, Mihai.
I'll be focusing on the Wallet
API for mobile payments.
I'm really excited to be here,
and hello everyone, hoping to
see you in the near future for
more of these sessions.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right, we'll
be counting on you.
Tell us a little bit about
the interview process.
We've been telling people that
we're hiring, and we have a
pipeline of great candidates,
and you were one of the best.
How was it?
NASIR KHAN: Absolutely.
So when I started out with the
interview process I was a
little nervous because you hear
and read these things
online that it's a really
excruciating process.
MIHAI IONESCU: A little bit.
NASIR KHAN: It was intensive,
I would say, but it was very
interesting, too, at
the same time.
So it was a very interesting
day overall.
I really liked it.
It was pretty smooth.
And it turned out
well in the end.
MIHAI IONESCU: Awesome,
awesome.
Yeah, we took it--
we took it easier on you.
NASIR KHAN: Thank
you for that.
MIHAI IONESCU: And you're
really good.
So we're very happy
to have you here.
PENG YING: How do you
like Google so far?
NASIR KHAN: It's been
an amazing ride.
I've just been about
a month now.
And every day is a new
day, literally.
Because there's so many
things to learn.
And in fact, the Payments
area, of course, is so
interesting, so diverse, and
really moving ahead in various
directions.
So it's very, very exciting
to be here.
MIHAI IONESCU: So many exciting
things happening.
Awesome.
Well, welcome, Nasir.
PENG YING: We're still hiring,
if anybody else is--
MIHAI IONESCU: We
are hiring, yes.
PENG YING: --interested in
joining the team as well.
MIHAI IONESCU: And we'll see
more of you in upcoming weeks.
All right.
So let's move on to some
announcements.
You've been traveling a lot.
What's been going on?
PENG YING: I have been
traveling, yeah.
Well, I just got back
from Kansas City.
And what we're doing there was
we were holding a Google for
Entrepreneurs event in Kansas
City, where we walked through
the APIs and the products that
we think can be beneficial to
entrepreneurs and developers.
So I went there, and I spoke
about Google Wallet for
digital goods, and was telling
them about a high-level
overview of what Google Wallet
is, and how it can benefit
developers and entrepreneurs
selling digital goods.
I also got to check out
Google Fiber, which is
something that is--
MIHAI IONESCU: All right!
Yes!
PENG YING: Yeah, totally
amazing.
MIHAI IONESCU: Oh, I envy you.
PENG YING: I think-- well, I
watch a lot of TV, which is
probably not the best thing,
but I'm using Comcast right
now, and the UI for Comcast,
Google Fiber blows it away.
It was amazing what you could
do using a 7-inch tablet as
your remote control and being
able to schedule DVR and
stuff, and then stream the DVR
content to the 7-inch tablet
while you're watching TV, like
some other channel on TV, it
was just a awesome experience.
And I'm totally excited for
people in Kansas City.
Giving you guys a shout out.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, I heard
that a lot of start-ups are
popping up in the Kansas
city area.
PENG YING: It seems like it.
We had pretty good attendance.
MIHAI IONESCU: Wow.
Great.
PENG YING: Cool.
Oh, one more thing.
I want to talk a little
about Stack Overflow.
So we've now pretty much fully
migrated from Google Groups
over to Stack Overflow.
And we're starting to
see a little bit--
we're starting to see more and
more questions about any
Google Wallet topic
on Stack Overflow.
So if you have questions about
Google Wallet APIs, such as
Checkout Google Wallet for
digital goods, Google Wallet
for online commerce,
Save-to-Wallet, or any of
those APIs, you can post them
in Stack Overflow and tag it
with Google-Wallet.
And then we pretty much check
almost every day.
And we'll try to answer
as many of those
questions as possible.
MIHAI IONESCU: So we're
counting on
the developer community.
If someone misses a question or
doesn't tag it correctly,
please re-tag it.
We'll be forever grateful.
OK, what else is going on?
Some exciting new launches.
Yeah, Nasir, do you want
to talk about it?
NASIR KHAN: Interesting, yeah.
So as I said, I'll be working
on the Google Payments, and
there are two new, exciting
devices that have just come on
the market--
LG Nexus 4 and Samsung
Nexus 10.
They have Google preinstalled
on them.
And they also have the
latest and greatest
4.2 Android on them.
PENG YING: 4.2.
MIHAI IONESCU: 4.2 is awesome.
PENG YING: I just got the
OTA this morning.
NASIR KHAN: You did?
OK, great.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PENG YING: I haven't got
to check it out yet.
I heard the Nexus 4 sold out in
something like 30 minutes.
MIHAI IONESCU: 30?
PENG YING: I could be wrong.
It might be like 50 minutes.
MIHAI IONESCU: No, it sold
out pretty fast.
But there are more on the way.
It's a very nice device,
so no wonder.
And it's a great price.
OK, so what else is going on?
Oh, I also have an
announcement.
So remember last time someone
asked about to open-ended
subscriptions?
So subscriptions with no
expiration date, you just set
the subscription, let it go,
and either it will end when
the customer cancels it or
the merchant cancels it.
So our engineering team
went to work.
Open-ended subscriptions are now
available, and I'm going
to switch to my screen and
show you guys how you
can set them up.
So if my screen is on, you
will see that we have a
"numRecurrences" field
in the JWT.
That is now optional.
If you are not setting it, if
you're omitting it, then the
subscription would be
open-ended, and it would recur
until canceled.
And to show you how a screen
will look like when a customer
places an open-ended
subscription, it'll look just
like this, and it will nicely
say "The subscription will
occur every month starting
when, until you cancel on
subscription/" So that all
means it's open-ended.
So for those who are looking
for this new
feature, it's there.
Go ahead and use it.
And we were happy that we had
such a fast turnaround.
So with that said, any
other announcements?
PENG YING: Pretty sweet.
MIHAI IONESCU: We will have
some interesting partners
joining us hopefully in
the next few sessions.
PENG YING: Yeah, in the
next few sessions.
We'll have Carbon Games
bringing on AirMech.
And then we'll have Kabam
talking about their
monetization and how they've
monetized their games.
MIHAI IONESCU: So don't miss
the next few sessions.
PENG YING:Yep.
Let's go to some questions.
MIHAI IONESCU: Questions,
yes, my
favorite part of the session.
So I'll take the first one.
So the first one is, "Can we
share revenue via the other
current or near-future
Google Wallet API?
Is this a beta program?
How can we sign up
to test it?"
So that is a very good question,
and it's coming up
frequently.
It is a valid business case and
something that a lot of
developers are looking
forward to.
Currently, there is no API that
allows you to do revenue
sharing, but it is on
our to-do list.
So we are working on it.
PENG YING: I'll take
the second one.
"Any word on support for the
Sprint Galaxy Note 2?" So, as
you know, we can't publicly
give stuff out before it's
announced here.
But I would say to check the
list of available devices in
the Help section on
wallet.google.com.
And it's at the bottom
of the page.
It's under Eligible Devices.
And we should be supporting
most of the
Galaxy devices on Sprint.
Take a look.
Maybe it's there already.
I haven't look at that page
for a little bit.
But if you're interested, go to
wallet.google.com and then
click Eligible Devices.
MIHAI IONESCU: Upgrade
to a Nexus 4.
PENG YING: Yeah.
Upgrade to--
Nexus 4 is an awesome phone.
I played with it a little bit.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK, so let
me take the next one.
And this one, the question is,
"How can I pass user- and
order-specific information on a
Google Wallet transaction?"
It's not clear from the question
which Google Wallet
API the developer
is using here.
So let's assume it's the digital
goods API, also called
the In-App Payments API.
With that, you have a field
called "Seller Data" in the
JWT, and you can pass any type
of information in that field.
It's nice if you encrypt
it to make sure no one
else can see it.
And then that information
will be mirrored back
to you in the postback.
So that's one way you
can pass private
information back and forth.
If you're using the Google
Checkout API, then you have a
similar field in the cart XML
and that's called "Merchant
Private Data"--
if you search for it, you'll
find it in the documentation--
similarly passed in the cart
XML, and you will get it back
in the notification API.
You'll have to subscribe to the
notification API, so very
similar mechanisms
and very useful.
PENG YING: Cool.
I'll take the next one.
"Is there any progress in
getting Google Wallet on
carriers such as AT&T, T-Mobile,
et cetera?" Again,
we can't really elaborate
on that.
I get all the questions where
I can't say anything.
Sorry, guys.
But we're still working
with them.
I can't get into any details.
So I guess next question.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, I don't
know if that's an easy
question or a hard question.
It's easy to answer,
but hard because we
can't give more details.
PENG YING: Yeah, that sucks.
I wish we could.
MIHAI IONESCU: We really
wish we could.
PENG YING: Yeah, transparency
is great.
MIHAI IONESCU: Let me
take the next one.
The question is, "How can I
redirect the customer back to
my site after a Google Checkout
transaction?" So in
Google Checkout, there is
no automatic redirect.
There is a "Continue Shopping"
URL field so that you can
specify, and that will
appear as a link on
the final order page.
The customer will need
to click on it to go
back to your site.
So it is not an automatic
action.
It is a user-initiated action.
And this is a one of the
drawbacks of the Checkout API.
If, however, you are selling
digital goods, definitely use
the Google Wallet for digital
goods API because it's
designed to be on all ENAP APIs,
so the customer never
leaves your site.
It all happens on your site.
So you have complete control
over the buy flow experience.
So something to consider,
depending on what kind of
goods you're selling.
Next question.
Let me take this one because
it's also about subscriptions.
PENG YING: All right.
Go for it.
MIHAI IONESCU: It's A little
bit down my alley.
So the question is, "When
testing recurring subscription
in the Sandbox, how can I verify
that my subscription
recurs on the correct date?
Do I have to wait a month, as
the only available frequency
is monthly?" So the nice thing
about the Sandbox is that you
can do all kinds of testing and
place order, cancel orders
without really incurring
me transaction costs.
So to verify that a subscription
recurs correctly,
you can play a little
bit with the JWT.
And let's say you set up a free
trial subscription that
recurs one day in the future.
So you set the first
subscription charge to occur
one day in the-- tomorrow.
And then you just wait one day,
and you verify on your
buyer account, did I get
the transaction email?
And you look in the
merchant account.
Did the transaction
appear there?
Can I cancel it?
So it's not as bad as it looks
with the monthly frequency.
You just need to play a little
bit with our JWT and get a
little bit creative.
PENG YING: I have a question
about subscriptions.
MIHAI IONESCU: Go ahead.
PENG YING: Are we going to
enable anything other than
monthly soon?
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes, we're
going to do that.
Most likely weekly should be
pretty easy to do, and then
three months, so quarterly
should also be easy.
We're looking at six months.
So we're verifying.
We're asking people which are
the most useful ones, and then
we'll go in that priority.
NASIR KHAN: I've seen monthly
and yearly subscriptions.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yearly
subscription is also very
popular, yes.
So we're looking at
all of those.
PENG YING: Cool.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK, you want
to look at the next one?
PENG YING: Sure, I'll take
this shipping one.
So it looks like somebody is
having trouble with Checkout.
And the question is,
"I have trouble
shipping with Checkout.
I use product weight to
calculate the shipping cost
from the table in the
Merchant Center.
One item has flat-rate
shipping with
product shipping class.
When this item is in the cart,
the customer is only charged
the flat rate."
MIHAI IONESCU: All right.
We need a little time
to parse this one.
It's quite technical.
PENG YING: I did a lot of
Checkout support in the past.
In order to troubleshoot this
issue, I would actually need
the cart XML.
It's the clearest way to
understand what's going wrong.
But from this description
and from my experience
troubleshooting shopping carts
and Checkout, I think what's
going on is that the carts that
are being submitted, it
also includes shipping
information within the cart.
So that shipping information
is then overriding--
it takes precedence over the
Merchant Center configuration.
So if you've set up your
shipping tables in the
Merchant Center,
and you have--
like let's say you're using
e-commerce platform, and this
e-commerce platform is
generating some shipping
information in the
cart itself.
That shipping information
that's generated by the
e-commerce platform will take
precedence, and that's what
Checkout will use to
charge a customer.
And that could be what's
happening here.
MIHAI IONESCU: Most
likely, yeah.
PENG YING: If it's not, if
you're looking at the XML cart
and it's not working, maybe try
posting the question on
Stack Overflow, and then include
your XML cart, and
include what you're seeing,
a description
of what you're seeing.
And then we'll try
to take look.
MIHAI IONESCU: Definitely we're
going to be parsing also
the Stack Overflow stream for
more technical questions.
Unfortunately, this is a
Moderator question, and you're
limited as far as how
much information
you can put in there.
So I can understand why this was
hard to express what the
problem is.
So Stack Overflow with code
samples, and we're going to
look at them.
And maybe we can
debug it live.
That would be fun.
PENG YING: Debugging live.
It's coming.
I swear.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK, so it
looks like we're at
the end of the questions.
The next couple weeks are
going to be exciting.
PENG YING: Yeah, Thanksgiving
next week.
Gobble, gobble.
MIHAI IONESCU: And after that,
another Payments Live session.
PENG YING: Yeah, we're
definitely going to be another
Payments Live session.
We'll have AirMech on.
I don't know if you guys have
heard of AirMech or played
with AirMech at all.
Well, right now it's kind of
like a defense of the Ancient
style game.
If you don't know that, it's
kind of like a competitive
Tower Defense game.
And then basically the reason
why it's amazing is because of
the technology that
they've built and
enabled into the browser.
So we'll be showing this
awesome-looking game in the
browser, and then we'll be
talking to them about how
they've monetized the game, the
method of monetization,
which in their case
is freemium.
So we'll be discussing a little
bit about the freemium
methodology, and then if it's
been successful for them, and
maybe you'll find
some insights.
MIHAI IONESCU: It's an excellent
use case of how you
can use the digital goods API to
monetize a browser app for
any kind of game.
All right.
Well, thank you.
And thank you, Nasir,
for joining us.
We'll see everyone next time.
Bye.
PENG YING: See ya.
[MUSIC PLAYING]